FEMALE SPEAKER:
Google Cloud Platform
has many tools
available to Rubyists.
Today I'm going to talk
to you about two of them,
App Engine and the Gcloud Gem.
App Engine flexible environments
is our latest platform
as a service offering.
With App Engine, you can
focus on writing your code.
And we'll take care of
setting up the web server
and scaling your
application as needed.
App Engine for Ruby supports
both Rails and Sinatra.
And we have code samples for
both to help you get started.
You can also use the
database of your choice,
whether that's our managed MySQL
compatible Database Cloud SQL
or running your own MySQL,
Postgres, or Mongo database.
To use App Engine to run
your Ruby application,
start by creating a project
in the Google Cloud Platform
console and installing the
Gcloud STK on your computer.
Like Rails, App
Engine uses YAML files
to configure your application.
This app.yaml specifies that
we should use the Ruby runtime
and sets an entry point.
The entry point is
the command that
should be used to
run your application.
Once you've written
your app.yaml,
you can use Gcloud preview
app deploy to deploy
your application to App Engine.
Once the application
has deployed,
you can use Gcloud
preview app browse
to launch a browser pointed
at your application.
This is our app running.
As you can see, the default
domain for App Engine projects
is your project ID .appspot.com.
In addition to App
Engine for Ruby,
there are many other
services that are
part of Google Cloud Platform.
The Gcloud Gem was written
by Rubyists for Rubyists.
It makes interacting
with the cloud
platform products from your
Ruby applications feel natural.
The Gcloud Gem supports
BigQuery, data store,
cloud DNS, cloud logging,
resource manager, translate,
pub/sub, and cloud storage.
Support for cloud vision and
more products is coming soon.
The Gcloud Ruby
project is open source.
Check it out on the Google
Cloud Platform or on GitHub.